Thông báo của tổng thống Mỹ về thời thỏng ngừng bắn sống mấy ngày tại giải khá ra,
lánh giấu một bân hoặc mới khi yên xerang đồng ý về người tác với tất cả điều kiện cình thiết.
Ablực đăng dồ linh Hamas trong việc đưa ra phản hồi, chứ bối cảnh thương vòng gia tăng và cập đồng
của tế kêu hỏi chấm giết chính sử. Tuy nhiên, chứ cuối gì bảo đam rằng, câu ở nay sẽ chuyển thành
hoa bình bình bứng. Một ký bản khả quan, là Hamas chấp nhận để sốt, mở đường chứ một
tổng thống cho đường con tìm và tụi nhân, tạo kiên nế chứ đàn phản xọc hơn về kế thuộc của xung đồ.
Thì bản thứ hai là Hamas từ chỗ điều kiện hiện tại khiến i Sarain thích tục chính xí quân sự,
điều đưa kánh báo sống sàng từ việc trên nha viết. Thì bản thứ ba khó đoán tình hơn,
là các bên tà đuổi tổng thống tạm thời, nhưng xung đồn vẫn em bị giòn thiếu căng thiết giải hạng và lòng tiên chính trị.
Dù thế nào, sống mấy ngày gần bắn, điều thành hiện thực sẽ là khoảng lần cình thiết để cú trực nhận đạo.
Thái thiết thơ sửa hạ tần và tài định hình lại bức trang chính trị trung đông đàn phân mạnh.